hi there it's cusco
and uh i haven't been able to put up
many videos
because very often the wi-fi isn't very
good
and so i can't upload them but
and i didn't sleep very well last night
must be because of the
high elevation here in cusco
and but i stepped in away from the noise
of the street to this courtyard
so that i could do a little video and
update you and
so we've had nine days in argentina
nine days
in brazil and now we're starting our
peruvian adventure
and of course one of the things is
argentina speaks spanish
brazil speaks portuguese and
here in peru of course they speak
spanish again
so i speak spanish a lot better than i
speak portuguese
and of course a big difficulty in both
spanish and portuguese
is the verbs
the verb endings
tenses
and knowing
which form of the verb it is in some
cases
and being able to produce it correctly
while speaking
so i thought i would share some of my
approaches to this so obviously i have a
lot more trouble in portuguese than i
have in spanish
um
the endings are different in portuguese
they also have
verbs that aren't used in spanish like
um i know ashar lambrades
and so
what ends up happening is that you're
speaking and you're never sure at least
i am not sure as i'm speaking portuguese
is this a spanish word or is this a
portuguese word so i have doubts
and this is the correct ending or not
the correct ending and i have these
doubts and doubts are very bad because
it then holds you back very often your
gut instinct
is correct if you just go with it rather
than
doubting whether it's the correct form
or the correct word
and even if you get it wrong
it doesn't really matter people
understand what you're saying
and also very often you are aware that
you doubt it or you weren't totally sure
or maybe you got it wrong
and that at least in my case heightens
my
awareness of that word or form so then
what happens is when i'm reading and of
course i do a lot of reading here i've
bought books on argentinian history
brazilian history peruvian history
so i'm reading and wherever i see a word
a verb form
or other phrases but typically mostly
verb forms that i'm not totally sure of
i underline them in the book
if i am on link which i
was doing a lot of for portuguese
then what i really recommend and i think
i've mentioned this before is context
reversal so i will look up a verb
which appeared in a certain form in a
sentence i may even know that verb so
i'm not really looking for the meaning
of that verb but i open up
the the link widget
and immediately go to context reversal
because what context reverso does
it highlights that'll give you like the
whole
all the conjugations of that verb
but it will highlight the one that you
chose the one that's in that text
so it kind of does two things first of
all it tells you what form that is
it highlights it in all of the
conjugation tables plus in order to get
to that you kind of have a quick review
of the other
um you know tenses and and persons and
so forth and so on and so doing these
things whether you're on link and you're
using context reversal or just reading
in a book and underlying verb forms
i find that this
gradually makes you
better
and and yet when you go to speak you
still have to just go with it not doubt
yourself
just say whatever you want to say and
hope it's right
but i think this sort of
poking at the verb either by underlying
it in a book or if you're on link and
you're accessing context reverso or even
if you're
not reading on link but you're on a
website somewhere you can access context
reversal and see
which is the appropriate which is the
actual form that you were looking at
gradually builds up your ability to
produce it correctly when you need it so
that's what i wanted to say
and i'm going to go and have some
breakfast now and try to upload this
hopefully the wi-fi at the hotel is good
enough
i should add that
really enjoying it here so far in peru
love the people very energetic they seem
uh friendly the brazilians especially in
rio were just amazing in their
enthusiastic friendliness
uh
in salvador
equally so although a bit of a negative
up there is the over aggressive people
selling their wares in the old town
uh but by and large it's been a
wonderful trip and um
yeah i'm looking forward to
uh wandering around cusco today and then
tomorrow we're going to machu picchu bye
for now
[Music]